aussi sur facebook et sur les réseaux
sociaux j'aimerais bien qu'à un moment
autour de cette table on dise les choses
les chéris que franchement arrêtez de
tourner autour du pot
il ya eu à un boycott sur les réseaux
sociaux
vous le savez tous personne ne veut le
dire ici sur facebook sur twitter sur
install murin il ya plein de gens qui
ont appelé au boycott des [ __ ] il
faut le dire et 600 mille
téléspectateurs au moins ou un peu plus
ne me dites pas que c'est à cause de ça
il ya eu 800 mille téléspectateurs de
moi je suis désolé il faut si vous
faites votre travail est dit long moment
voilà il faut quand même que les gens
disent gilles verdez oui bien sûr qu'il
ya eu un boycott mais mais franchement
cyril moi ce que je voulais vous dire
aussi et oui un boycott qui a été
organisée mais pour moi mais oui mais
pour moi l'émission en elle même était
mauvaise les jeunes à fuissé part ça les
jeunes ont fui la courbe elle dit pas de
bêtise la courbe est belle donc ces
légendes sont moins venus au départ moi
je pense que c'est un syndrome post
gilet jaune
je suis un petit peu d'accord avec vous
alors je pense que d'abord les gens
aujourd'hui avec les foulées jaunes ont
une détestation pour les artistes
en règle générale qui font ça un peu
pour leur pub 1 et donc en fait les
empharés ya un côté vivre ensemble il ya
un côté fraternité et les gilets jaunes
on dit d'un côté il ya les [ __ ] il ya
les artistes ya les riches à les nantis
et donc ils ne sont pas audibles et ne
sont pas crédit pour ce genre de
spectacle et je pense que ça fait
beaucoup de tort aux spectacles malgré
tout et que de quelque part le la france
moyenne et madame michu de tf1 la
ménagère qui regardent de lire regarder
ce spectacle naples n'avait plus envie
de regarder moi je vais vous dire la
vérité je trouve que les artistes qui
vont fonctionner welmant déjà ce
magnifique ce qu'ils font
franchement je vous dire c'est une
semaine c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail et ils vont tous pas
pour faire leur promo ils vont tous
parce que ils y vont pour la cause et
minéral c'est hyper important
aujourd'hui les restos du coeur on a
vraiment besoin d après je pense qu'il
aurait été malin qu'il aurait été
intéressant de faire un petit clin
d'oeil
moi j'aurais fait un petit clin d'oeil
aussi des choses dans le spectacle je
vous dis la vérité
voici bâti passe aussi des choses alors
oloron reprocher plaint de ne pas avoir
parlé d'eux j'aurais fait un petit truc
même un petit titre avec dedans
peut-être une parodie ou un truc un
petit clin d'oeil je pense que ça aurait
été le bienvenu voilà je peux presque
trop rapide peu de peu deux artistes se
sont exprimés pour soutenir les jo je
leur reproche pas et c'est je le sens ce
qui prime et était plutôt contre donc du
coup je pense que vu comme un petit
roger quand même bcp
après la tension est enrichie alors moi
je me suis je fais entièrement nourrit
des boeufs et le journal mais c'est vrai
j'ai entièrement d'accord avec
l'argument sur les gilet jaune ya quand
même mieux une pointe un pic à neuf
millions 9 donc c'est pas vrai que la
prime était pas bonne ça c'est vrai
c'est ça l'avenir
la courbe est bonne en revanche je hais
ce qu'ils auraient bien pris s'il y
avait une allusion au gilet jaune parce
que dans mon univers savait prendre
toujours tout malien sur son île ça
dépend comment c'est fait si ça a été
sympathique et qu'on découvre elle
cherche pas d ce nom non ça ne verras tu
en voilà plus à la page et les havrais
ont dit des bêtises et dans la rue
bernier roncq et non qualification ils
apportent vous disiez de très gentil ou
présent arrêté
non mais là la chaire a dit là vous
faites une génération et lorsque j'y
vais dans la démagogie aujourd'hui n'a
pas tu n'y a pas de solution aujourd'hui
à que des coupables il y avait les ont
marre et veulent des solutions ils
veulent offrir de la nourriture aux gens
ne les produits précités ont les gilets
jaunes ils veulent vivre décemment
j'aurais xavier frère à manifester merci
la rétine d'accord et oui mais oui je
vais pas aujourd'hui alors